Trascrizione: Sara Capobianco
Revisore: Michele Gianella
"L'uomo è l'unica specie
in grado di costruire armi
per uccidere se stessa"
Sono rimasta abbastanza attonita,
la prima volta
che ho sentito questa frase;
ma poi ho studiato biologia
e ho iniziato a lavorare
sull'inquinamento marino.
E ho iniziato a capire
che non è poi così falsa.
L'impatto dell'uomo sugli oceani
sta diventando sempre più profondo.
Ma è come se l'inquinamento marino
non fosse ancora percepito
come una vera e propria
minaccia alla nostra salute;
è come se noi sapessimo della presenza
dell'inquinamento in mare,
ma non volessimo vedere
quella linea sottile
che collega le nostre vite
alla salute degli oceani.
Io ho sempre avuto una particolare
passione per l'acqua;
nuoto da quando ero
veramente molto piccola,
e da adolescente ho iniziato
a fare immersioni.
Ed è stata proprio durante
una delle prime immersioni
che sono rimasta letteralmente ipnotizzata
dalla bellezza di quel mondo sottomarino.
Quel mondo che abbiamo
silenziosamente violentato,
i cui segni però sono
molto ben visibili, là sotto.
Sono una biologa marina,
e studio l'impatto dell'uomo sul mare;
lo faccio non solo perché voglio
conoscere ed esplorare,
ma anche perché voglio
comunicarlo agli altri,
a chi non si occupa di scienza.
Lo faccio perché voglio lasciare
alle generazioni future
un oceano più pulito,
in modo che anch'esse possano innamorarsi,
come è successo a me,
di quelle bellezze sottomarine,
e possano continuare questa catena
di protezione degli oceani,
che non si fermerà più.
Oggi voglio portarvi in un viaggio:
un viaggio al confine
tra il visibile e l'invisibile.
Un viaggio al confine
tra il macroscopico e il microscopico.
Un viaggio attraverso l'oceano,
per scoprire come l'inquinamento
da plastica, e i contaminanti chimici,
possono influenzare la nostra salute
e danneggiare il nostro pianeta.
Spesso l'inquinamento marino
è percepito come un qualcosa
che interessa solamente
le comunità costiere,
o di cui solo esse sono responsabili.
Ma in realtà, dovete sapere
che più dell'80 percento
dei rifiuti presenti in mare
è in realtà di origine terrestre,
e viene da aree anche
molto lontane dalla costa.
E poi arrivano in mare
attraverso apporti fluviali,
attraverso l'immissione diretta,
anche attraverso eventi
meteorologici avversi.
Una volta giunti in mare,
soltanto una piccola percentuale
in realtà galleggia,
meno del 15 percento è visibile
sul pelo dell'acqua.
La stragrande maggioranza invece affonda,
e va a formare, ed implementare,
delle vere e proprie
discariche sottomarine.
Pensate che siamo riusciti
a far arrivare la plastica
persino nel posto
più buio, più inesplorato
e più profondo dei nostri oceani:
a 11.000 metri di profondità,
presso la Fossa delle Marianne.
Ma lo sapevate che esistono
degli ammassi di rifiuti
grandi quanto cinque volte
la superficie dell'Italia,
che stanno attualmente
galleggiando sugli oceani?
Infatti, negli oceani esistono
delle gigantesche correnti,
che si chiamano Vortex,
proprio perché hanno un andamento
circolare, vorticoso e continuo;
queste trasportano i rifiuti
e li accumulano al loro interno.
E quindi, giorno dopo giorno,
anno dopo anno,
si sono venuti a formare
questi grandi ammassi,
che impropriamente vengono chiamati
"isole di plastica",
ma che in realtà non sono
per niente delle isole:
sono dei veri e propri accumuli
di rifiuti galleggianti.
La stragrande maggioranza
di questi rifiuti
è costituita da plastica monouso
e attrezzi da pesca.
Infatti il fenomeno
delle reti fantasma, ad esempio,
è sempre più diffuso
nei mari di tutto il mondo.
Le reti fantasma sono delle reti da pesca
che vengono volontariamente,
o spesso involontariamente,
abbandonate nel mare;
e queste là sotto continuano a pescare,
ma poi non c'è nessun pescatore
che le salpa a bordo.
E quindi, gli animali intrappolati
muoiono di una lenta agonia.
Ma la plastica può essere anche ingerita:
infatti, la maggior parte dei cetacei
che vengono trovati spiaggiati
lungo le coste del nostro pianeta
vengono trovati con chili
e chili di plastica
all'interno del loro stomaco.
Per non parlare, poi,
della situazione degli uccelli marini.
Pensate che gli adulti cibano
con la plastica i propri pulcini,
quindi i piccoli crescono già
con la plastica all'interno:
ed hanno gravissimi
problemi di malnutrizione,
problemi di crescita,
e molti di essi non riescono
a raggiungere l'età adulta.
Ma se la plastica non intrappola,
o non venisse ingerita,
qual è il suo destino?
Beh, se questa bottiglietta
finisse in mare
sarebbe soggetta, immediatamente,
all'azione dei raggi
ultravioletti del sole,
o alla forza meccanica delle onde,
e a molti altri agenti;
e quindi mese dopo mese, anni dopo anni,
il materiale plastico inizia
a frammentarsi e a degradarsi sempre più.
E quindi, una singola bottiglietta
di plastica, che adesso vediamo,
può trovarsi in mare
nella sua forma invisibile:
le microplastiche.
Le microplastiche
sono particelle di plastica
di dimensioni inferiori
ai cinque millimetri.
Magari vi state chiedendo:
ma come ci arrivano in mare,
le microplastiche?
Beh, ci sono le microplastiche primarie,
che diventano così piccole
ancor prima di raggiungere il mare.
Ad esempio, quelle microsfere abrasive
che vengono incluse in molti cosmetici
vengono rilasciate attraverso
gli scarichi urbani
e raggiungono l'ambiente.
Ci sono poi le microfibre,
che sono dei minuscoli filamenti
rilasciati dalle nostre lavatrici
ogni volta che laviamo
capi di abbigliamento
in tessuto sintetico.
Ci sono poi le microplastiche secondarie,
chiamate così perché diventano
così piccole in un secondo momento,
cioè dopo il processo
di degradazione e frammentazione
di oggetti di plastica più grandi,
proprio come è successo
alla nostra bottiglia di plastica.
Uno dei grandi problemi
legati alle microplastiche
è che possono essere facilmente ingerite:
infatti, come i grandi animali
ingeriscono plastica,
i piccoli animali marini
possono ingerire plastica
nella sua forma microscopica.
Diversi anni fa mi sono chiesta:
"Ma come mai gli animali marini
dovrebbero ingerire microplastiche?
Le microplastiche,
nell'ambiente acquatico,
attirano sulla propria superficie
tantissimi composti presenti nell'acqua;
e questi composti vanno a formare
un vero e proprio tappetino molecolare,
tutto intorno alla superficie,
che si chiama eco-corona.
Ora, questa eco-corona
funge da terreno di colonizzazione
per molti microrganismi marini
come batteri marini,
microalghe, funghi marini;
quindi si viene proprio a formare
un vero e proprio micro habitat
intorno ad una minuscola
particella di plastica.
E questa si chiama plastisfera.
Dunque la plastisfera, vivendo,
produce tantissime molecole,
che rilascia nell'ambiente circostante;
tantissimi odori;
e quindi le microplastiche
odorano come cibo,
per molti organismi marini.
Ecco perché questi
sono tentati dal catturarle,
e quindi a ingerirle.
Su questa eco-corona,
quindi su questo tappetino di molecole,
si trovano anche tante sostanze
che sono tossiche per la vita.
E questi contaminanti chimici
possono intervenire
e provocare degli effetti
dannosi in diverse maniere.
Ma un effetto che mi ha particolarmente
interessato qualche anno fa,
e che poi ho studiato
durante il mio lavoro,
è l'interferenza endocrina.
Dunque, gli interferenti endocrini
sono delle sostanze,
o dei miscugli di sostanze,
che hanno la capacità
di disturbare il sistema ormonale.
Infatti la maggior parte di essi opera
semplicemente mimando gli ormoni;
infatti la loro struttura chimica
è molto, molto simile
a quella degli ormoni,
non solo umani ma anche animali;
e quindi, una volta
che entrano in un organismo,
agiscono al loro posto,
e il corpo non riesce a riconoscerli
come dei composti estranei;
per cui a me piace chiamarli
impostori molecolari,
proprio perché agiscono
come dei veri e propri impostori.
Gli interferenti endocrini
possono agire in diverse misure:
ad esempio, possono provocare infertilità,
possono provocare problemi
di sviluppo e di crescita,
problemi riproduttivi, obesità, diabete,
e molti altri disturbi e malattie.
Ma nell'ambiente marino,
mi ha incuriosito molto
uno degli effetti,
che è la confusione sessuale;
infatti adesso voglio raccontarvi
un aneddoto un po' scientifico.
Allora, qualche decade fa
dei biologi marini
hanno iniziato a osservare,
in diverse parti del pianeta,
delle decimazioni di lumachine di mare;
sono riusciti poi a correlare
queste decimazioni di questi molluschi
ad alte concentrazioni
di "TBT" nell'ambiente.
Dunque, il "TBT",
anche definito tributilstagno,
è praticamente un composto
che veniva, fino agli anni ottanta,
aggiunto alle vernici anti vegetative
che sono usate per rivestire
la chiglia delle navi
ed evitare che organismi marini
le vadano a colonizzare.
Be', questo "TBT" è un biocida,
e un potentissimo interferente endocrino.
E pensate che tra i suoi vari effetti
è riuscito a mascolinizzare
le femmine di queste lumachine.
Il "TBT" ha, letteralmente,
fatto crescere un pene
sulle femmine di questi gasteropodi.
Siamo davvero arrivati a un limite.
Dobbiamo sapere
che tutti questi contaminanti
sono di origine antropica,
ed è proprio a causa dell'uomo
se finiscono in mare.
Questo ci serve a far capire
che l'uomo e l'oceano sono
strettamente correlati tra loro.
Mi piace tantissimo
una frase di Rachel Carson;
Rachel Carson è stata
una biologa, una scrittrice,
una forte attivista statunitense
che grazie alle sue denunce è riuscita
a far abolire l'uso del DDT,
che è anch'esso un potente
interferente endocrino.
Lei scriveva:
"In natura, niente esiste da solo.
Ma l'uomo è parte integrante della natura,
e la sua guerra contro la natura
è inevitabilmente
una guerra contro se stesso".
Beh tutto questo sembra una triste storia,
ma in realtà voglio dirvi una cosa.
Qualche anno fa ho incontrato di persona
la fantastica oceanografa Silvia Earl;
e lei, durante il nostro
discorso, mi ha detto:
"Martina, l'inquinamento da plastica
ha un lato negativo
ma anche un lato positivo".
E tra me mi sono chiesta:
"Ma quale potrebbe essere
il lato positivo?"
"Il lato negativo è che la plastica
sta distruggendo i nostri oceani.
Ma il lato positivo è che noi lo sappiamo,
e quindi possiamo ancora fare qualcosa
per salvare il nostro pianeta".
Attualmente io, e magari tutti voi,
ci stiamo chiedendo:
"Ma che cosa possiamo fare in realtà? "
Io, onestamente, non penso che ci sia
la soluzione per eccellenza;
Io penso che sia necessario
uno sforzo integrato
tra istituzioni, amministrazioni locali,
comunità, scienziati,
innovatori, comunicatori.
Sono già stati fatti molti passi
nella direzione giusta,
come ad esempio l'abolizione
dell'uso delle microplastiche
all'interno dei cosmetici;
o il recentissimo DDL, nel Trentino,
nel rilasciare palloncini nell'atmosfera.
Ma c'è bisogno di un passo in più,
e c'è bisogno della
collaborazione di tutti,
perché tutti siamo cittadini del pianeta,
e ogni decisione che prendiamo,
ogni passo che facciamo,
deve lasciare un'impronta blu.
Io dico sempre che l'inquinamento
inizia dalle nostre scelte,
per cui facciamo la scelta giusta:
scegliamo il pianeta.
Grazie.
(Applausi)